[Music]
I think that if women are chilled and
children are appearing at the United
states-mexico border we can pretty much
surmise that there's no place left for
them to go the sounds you just heard
have come to signify one of the darkest
moments in recent American history but
it's a story that has roots that go back
almost 40 years the Central American
immigrant population in the United
States has increased more than tenfold
since 1980 in no small part because of
US intervention in that region Central
American communities became the focus of
the Trump administration's zero
tolerance policy towards people crossing
the mexico-us order in the spring of
2018 the policy introduced and enforced
by Attorney General Jeff Sessions
arrested any and all people caught
crossing prosecuting them immediately
the most controversial aspect of the
policy was the forced separation of
children of all ages from their parents
and their subsequent detention in what
some have called concentration camps but
what's been missing from the
conversation and coverage has been one
simple question why are these families
even coming here on the one hand you're
creating conditions that make this place
unlivable and on the other hand you're
not recognizing that the conditions are
unlivable and you're claiming that
people don't have a right to be here we
did not let them into this country even
though we had a hand in fueling the
civil unrest hey guys I'm Senna and this
Sunday I'm gonna be exploring how
decades of US intervention in Central
America has forced thousands of families
to Fleet for the mexico-us border today
[Music]
the history of US intervention and
involvement in Central America is a
story of destabilization bloodshed and a
vicious cycle of the export of violence
and control over resources lacey Abreu
and associate professor at UCLA who
focuses on Central American immigration
talks a bit more about that the
relationship between the u.s. and
Central America is a long and rather
complex one that started from the time
that the u.s. became a nation wanting to
make sure that other major political
powers were not stepping into what they
consider to be part of their territory
to some extent now we're gonna talk
about the Sandinistas civil wars
cia-backed death squads ms-13 but first
some context the United States history
of occupation and intervention in Latin
America spans almost 200 years from Cuba
to Haiti to Venezuela to Chile to Panama
to Nicaragua the United States was there
President James Monroe in 1823 declared
all of Latin America to be a US sphere
of influence under the Monroe Doctrine
Washington claimed the right to
intervene militarily across the
continent that led to the banana Wars in
which the United States military fought
to reassert American power and monopoly
of plantations in Central America Mexico
and the Caribbean land in Central
America was pretty fertile and there
were a lot of US corporations that had
established businesses there and those
interests were constantly protected
those business folks had an ear at the
US government so that anytime
that there were attempts in the region
to try and level some of the
inequalities there the US government
would step in there were coos there was
military intervention throughout the
1900s the US invasion of Nicaragua in
particular as part of those banana Wars
would lead to a 21-year long American
occupation the u.s. occupation of
Nicaragua came to an end when the Great
Depression and a rebellion led by
Augusto Nicolas Calderon santino forced
them to withdraw Santina was a
revolutionary who is still celebrated in
Nicaragua today he was assassinated in
1934 by the US train National Guard led
by General Anastasio Somoza Garcia who
led a us-backed coup d'etat two years
later it's one of the many coos across
Latin America that's characterized u.s.
foreign policy in the region since the
early 20th century Somoza and his family
would continue to rule in a garage WA
under a brutal dictatorship for the next
40 years sandino's revolutionary legacy
however was adopted by the left-leaning
sandanista front who would become the
greatest opposition to the dictatorship
but I'll get back to them in just a
minute
throughout this period the 1930s the 40s
the 50s there's a lot of us meddling in
Latin America in Central America in
particular that's happening and this
history is about to get a little
complicated but it shows the
intersection of US foreign policy toward
Central America at the height of the
Cold War and the spread of leftist
movements and revolutions the success of
the Cuban Revolution made the u.s.
nervous to think that there could be
political superpowers like
the USSR at the time getting involved in
what they perceive as their backyard all
of this set the stage for a sustained
and violent US intervention across
Central America during the 1980s backing
vicious local allies in wars that
claimed hundreds of thousands of lives
displaced Millions
and set in motion the social breakdown
that today forces many thousands to flee
north the way that the u.s. trained
those soldiers and tactics like extreme
torture and scorched earth tactics that
were really meant to instill fear in a
widespread way throughout those
populations that's what caused for the
first time people to flee
mass numbers let's start with Guatemala
from 1960 to 1996 Guatemala experienced
the longest civil war in Central America
it was fought between a u.s. installed
military dictatorship and leftist groups
true to its commitment to fighting
communism at all costs
the CIA provided intelligence training
and armed support to the Guatemalan
government throughout the war I also
want to mention here that Guatemala was
ruled by a right-wing military
government one of many since a 1954
us-backed coup that ousted a
democratically elected leftist president
the war claimed over 200,000 lives with
83% of them being indigenous mind people
people who lived mainly in rural areas
and were accused of being communist
supporters over half a million people
were displaced and over 40,000 were
disappeared mostly as a result of
government actions then there was
Nicaragua and the Sandinistas the early
80s saw a wave of leftist Cuban Soviet
aligned movements vying for power in
Nicaragua and El Salvador the Sandinista
National Liberation Front was founded in
1961 there are far left revolutionary
group that was opposed to Somoza
government in 1979 they overthrew the
Somoza dictatorship and two years later
they consolidated power with other
leftist groups prior tests and most of
government's fault President Jimmy
Carter actually started a covert policy
of supporting a more with the u.s.
called moderate opposition to the
government as an alternative to the
far-left opposition it was a policy that
both he and his successor Ronald Reagan
also pursued in El Salvador when civil
war broke out between the us-backed
military junta and the FMLN a coalition
of leftist groups Central America's
problems do directly affect the security
and the well-being of our own vegan and
Central America is much closer to the
United States than many of the world
trouble spots that concerns Reagan
invested heavily in an effort to roll
back this left-wing tide by arming
training and supporting government
forces and death squads in El Salvador
Honduras Guatemala and the rebel Contras
in Nicaragua the purpose of the Contras
the death squads was to fight against
Marxist groups vying for power and to
scare people away from supporting these
groups will we permit the Soviet Union
to put a second Cuba a second Libya
right on the doorstep of the United
States this was a policy of making sure
that communism would not spread
throughout the world we basically gave
arms munitions war implements money to
one side of a civil unrest to try and
stamp out communism for the most part at
least that was our goal at least that's
what was stated there was a slaughter
people lost their lives people lost
their livelihoods the Salvadoran Civil
War which lasted 12 years claimed over
75,000 lives and more than a quarter of
the population was displaced according
to a United Nations Truth Commission 85
percent of the violence was attributed
to the us-backed government and death
squads and 5% to the FMLN
back in Nicaragua the United States
spent over 1 billion dollars on the
contrast with Reagan calling them the
equivalent of the founding fathers of
the United States the u.s. also used
Honduras as a base for attacks against
the Sandinistas
in fact the u.s. helped transport
Honduran troops into Nicaragua and even
deployed its own soldiers into Honduras
to assist so the u.s. escalated a series
of local political conflicts throughout
the 1980s into a series of connected
wars that devastated Central America
which had started before the 80s and
intensify during that decade creating
massive social and economic breakdown
and human displacement we're still
feeling the impact of those wars today
almost 1 million Nicaraguan Salvadorans
Hondurans and Guatemalans fled to the
United States between 1980 and 1991 to
escape political repression and economic
hardship people fled to the United
States Los Angeles was a hotbed that
receives 70,000 immigrants during the
80s seeking asylum we did not let them
into this country even though we had a
hand in fueling the civil unrest and
that led to traumatize communities in
the United States with no mental-health
recourse and resources fending for
themselves not having refugee status not
being able to apply for asylum because
the vast majority of asylum applications
were denied at the time they were here
and they were undocumented and they had
to work to three jobs to survive so
gangs arose in this country in LA in
particular as a way to find support to
survive the communities
living in that led to all kinds of
activity that put them in prison and
then later in deportation and the point
of Rachel makes about gangs is an
important one in understanding the gang
violence that central Americans are
fleeing and how that's connected to the
refugees and migrants at the mexico-us
border Bill Clinton's 1996 immigration
reform act expanded the criteria for who
was deportable to include green card
holders and immigrants who had committed
a crime or anyone in a gang
so we deported 50,000 criminals from our
jails to El Salvador to a country that
had no law enforcement or a new law
enforcement structure it had just come
through a civil war and those gangs
easily reconstituted in El Salvador they
became very powerful and now they're
basically fighting with the local
government to rule the country
so ms-13 was generated in the United
States sent back to a country that
couldn't handle the criminal element and
now they've actually grown stronger so
we have a large responsibility in
playing a part in ms-13
it's not just coming from Central
America and it's not as though the
United States stopped intervening in
Central America once the civil wars came
to an end in 2009 a military coup
approved by the Honduran Supreme Court
rousted democratically elected leftist
President Manuel Zelaya
while President Barack Obama condemned
the coup then Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton advised that the u.s. now
branded as such since doing so would
force the United States seize all a to
hundreds the result a legitimized coup
and oust a democratic leader and
increase instability and violence in
fact homicides in Honduras increased by
50 percent in just three years the coup
notably also led to crackdown on
activists most famously the murder of
Berta Caceres an award-winning
indigenous environmental activist and
under the Trump administration there
have been efforts to significantly scale
back a to Latin America with big cuts to
aid to Central America instead efforts
have turned towards increasing
securitisation funding so with almost
200 years of American economic and
military involvement in Central America
does the United States have a moral
responsibility towards the people the US
has a responsibility a moral one to
provide the kinds of resources that
would stabilize a region that it has
destabilize so many times throughout the
region's history we're dealing with it
from a military perspective build a wall
put more boots on the ground incarcerate
people we're not dealing with the root
causes of migration we're not touching
the root causes of migration desperate
people will continue to come they will
scale the wall they will use organized
crime to get across they're desperate
they have no other choice but to fight
the system that we're putting them up
against hey guys thanks for watching let
us know what you thought of the video
and also let us know what are some other
histories of US intervention around the
world that you want us to cover and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe